Рівень вакцинації від COVID-19 серед українців - найнижчий у Європі.
Складається парадоксальна ситуація: на тлі стрімкого
зростання кількості інфікованих коронавірусом та
даних про високу смертність українці, схоже, досі більше бояться
вакцини, ніж ризику зараження. DW з’ясовувала чому.
У країнах Західної Європи, вакцинувати почали
наприкінці грудня минулого року. До України першу невелику партію
вакцин завезли лише через два місяці.
Щеплювавали громадян поетапно - спочатку пріоритетні групи.
Однак для українських реалій це було хибне рішення, вважають експерти.
Ми взяли модель вакцинації з країн, де є величезний попит на вакцини,
і застосували її на країну, де є низький попит на вакцини.
І через це ніхто не вакцинувався. Ми чекали аж до червня,
поки уряд не відмовився від цього плану, не відкрив масову вакцинацію,
і тоді нарешті у нас почалася нормальна кампанія.
На думку експертів, провальною була й початкова
піар-кампанія вакцинації. Як наслідок - люди не йшли робити щеплення,
бо чекали вакцин від "кращих" виробників,
а від препаратів, вироблених у Китаї та Індії, відмовлялися.
Масовий доступ до західних вакцин, таких як "Пфайзер/Байонтех"
і "Модерна", з'явився лише наприкінці літа, коли показники
захворюваності в Україні були незначними і українцям здавалося,
що пандемія вже майже позаду. Тож, було втрачено дорогоцінний час.
Треба правильно розставити акценти.
Треба боротися не з вакцинацією як такою,
а боротися за відповідальну, якісну вакцинацію,
хорошими препаратами,  підготовленими людьми,
щоб вони розуміли алгоритми, коли, якою вакциною, що їм робити
в тій чи іншій ситуації, як їм діяти після вакцинацій.
Ось це люди мають знати.
Згідно з опитуваннями, 80 відсотків українців
не довіряють державному апарату. Тому чиновницькі ініціативи
і, зокрема, заклики робити щеплення більшість населення
сприймає вкрай скептично. Це ілюструє ситуація
з обмеженнями у міжобласних перевезеннях:
черга за дорогим тестом на вокзалах довша, ніж за безплатним
щепленням. А також високий попит людей на купівлю фальшивих
COVID-сертифікатів: замість того, щоб отримати безкоштовну вакцину,
люди готові платити кілька тисяч гривень
за підроблений документ. Дехто боїться також
простої халатності: чи правильно зберігалася і транспортувалася
вакцина, чи не прострочена вона. Шкодить і позиція
значної частини українських медиків.
Стосовно лікарів, дуже велика є довіра не до системи медицини,
а до особистого лікаря, якогось знайомого лікаря.
Це і переваги, і недоліки. Дуже є багато серед
медичного персоналу скептиків щодо вакцинації.
І коли вони починають розповсюджувати скепсис
серед людей, - ця інформація як радіація.
Бо лікар сказав або медична сестра сказала,
що не треба вакцинуватися, і це має високу вагу, бо це ж медики.
Вчитель, який проти вакцинації, лікар, який проти,
політик, який проти - для мене це взагалі не зрозуміло,
як це може бути таке в 21-му сторіччі!
Чимало міфів лікарі також поширюють і
щодо ризиків вакцинації для груп ризику - людей,
які перші мали б захистити себе від коронавірусу щепленням.
МОЗ - це перший орган, який має комунікувати про те,
як правильно вакцинувати онкопацієнтів.
У лікарів не було жодних рекомендацій.
Я коли прийшла до сімейної лікарки, вона,
оскільки у мене є історія онкозахворювання,
боялася мене вакцинувати. Я показувала
їй міжнародні протоколи, як вакцинують онкопацієнтів.
Це насправді дуже дивно і дуже страшно, як на мене.
Також деякі експерти вважають, що владі варто було
включити медпрацівників до списку професій,
які підлягають обов'язковому щепленню.
Я почув пояснення, що якщо лікар відмовляється
- невже ми не допустимо його на роботу,
невже ми можемо це дозволити?
Але у мене на це є контраргумент: а якщо лікар захворіє на "ковід",
а якщо він помре? То ми його втратимо назавжди.
За деякими опитуваннями, найбільше мешканці України
бояться побічних ефектів, що можуть виникнути після щеплення.
Особливо якихось ще невідомих довгострокових
наслідків вакцини. Утім, ВООЗ уже неодноразово
спростовувала цей міф, наголошуючи:
довгострокові наслідки може мати сама хвороба.
А наслідки вакцини можуть спостерігатися
максимум 4-6 тижнів. Серед факторів,
що позитивно впливають на готовність щеплюватися
від "ковіду", 34 відсотки українців вказують передусім
позитивний досвід вакцинації у знайомих та родичів.
У соцмережах активно розганяють пости з різними теоріями змов.
Приміром, що вакцинація - це шлях до тотального контролю
над людством, геноцид української нації або
змінюють ДНК людини. Жодні з цих тверджень не мають
нічого спільного з доказовою медициною і реальною
ситуацією з COVID-19. Чимало таких постів розганяють
не справжні люди, а боти. Згідно з розслідуванням видання Liga.net,
майже 8 тисяч ботів активно писали негативні коментарі
про вакцинацію під постами у Facebook.
Експерти сподіваються, що нинішні рекордні показники
інфікування й смертності від коронавіруса
все ж спонукають українців змінити свою думку
і зробити щеплення.
У тих областях, які увійшли у "червону" зону
і сказали, що щеплення - це обов'язок,
рівень вакцинації одразу підскочив.
Це не тому, що людей заставляють. Просто є багато людей,
яким потрібен легкий копнячок під одне місце,
щоб вони щось зробили.
Експерти сходяться на тому, що вкрай необхідна
розумна просвітницька кампанія щодо вакцинації.
Так чи інакше, статистика з вакцинацією в Україні
все ще невтішна.
Двічі вакцинувалося лише 17 відсотків населення.
Це найнижчий показник у Європі.
Тим часом від коронавірусу загинуло
вже понад 65 тисяч українців.